[Music]
Samuel lives here and welcome to this
week's show and we are here with Joe
laine Joe good to add you on the show
yeah brilliant nice to be here you've
got an interesting background in fact
Joe you didn't really want me to bring
you on the show yet you were like can we
just wait a few months until I've got an
even more amazing story right yeah but
you are financially free I am yeah
full-time in property yeah well you just
give us a little bit of background about
yourself um I was in the room rent was
in there for eight and a half years so
served time in Afghanistan Iraq did some
time with the culture and guards working
in London I'm doing ceremonial I think
got injured so a really bad injury on
the ski slopes in Austria I was in a
coma for about three days and then spent
18 months relearning how to walk and
talk which is a bit emotional but a four
throat that's that's quite incredible
really I mean a coma for three days and
then had to learn to walk and talk all
over again that must have been
absolutely traumatic yeah it's one of
those things isn't it really you're
married at the time I wasn't married at
the time that's probably for the best
you wouldn't remember your wife know
exactly yeah
maybe you were mad at Tommy don't know
so you had that awful experience you
know what happened next work wise work
wise I probably worked out that the
wrong rings wasn't I wants to be on the
front line so that probably wasn't going
to be the way forwards yeah so I set up
the retail line for the rubbings charity
yeah um so made
www.normreeveshuntingtonbeach.com
there's pretty much a unit out there for
every every single Heric yeah I had
friends who were soft ripple amputees
and things and trying to fight their way
back yams I wanted to if I wanted that
your injury happened on a ski slope and
not you know actually it doing your job
pureum frustrating or whatever for my
mom she's very waves goodbye doesn't it
she went or waved goodbye when I was off
to Afghanistan Iraq
yeah probably fearing for the worst not
when you're scared not when you're going
that exactly yeah so how did property
come about then when did you decide that
you wanted to be a property investor and
how did that come about yeah I became an
accidental handled um I had a place back
in Poole and then that that was working
quite nicely I then had a friend who
recommended I went and a property event
down in Plymouth yeah and then you came
down to that did a really good talk I
ended up buying property from you
shortly afterwards yeah because it's
like in there this was a good couple of
years ago yeah was yeah back in 2016
maybe yeah so we met then and I remember
on the night talking about HMOs and how
a lot of people down south you think
that they can only buy houses down south
yeah but actually they might not
necessarily be the best return yeah and
we we looked at problems together didn't
we in Derby it wasn't Derby
yeah so that was your first kind of
proper investment property I saw being
accidental landlord right it was yeah
okay so so so how's that property going
it's working really well yeah sue
purpose or in a really good area yeah
pretty much could it rented the whole
time how much did you buy it for ninety
six five so you bought it for 96 500 and
did it in a big refurb needed about
fifteen twenty round okay it needed a
reasonably a reasonable refund and then
how much is it worth now pretty worth
about 120-130
okay so it's just so you've kept kept
its value yeah and how much you renting
out for fourteen hundred pounds fourteen
redress okay yeah so that's a decent
property with a return on investment of
what it's about 25 percent 25 percent
fantastic and you just complete it on a
property what today yeah yes like
yesterday yeah
I was living you anybody can play it it
was here yeah are you were here yeah so
um so tell us about that property then
that property's in Nottingham gets on
the brewer album scheme so boy refurb
refinance rent yeah I've done a joint
venture with a friend we managed to get
all five mice to get investors into us
and we bought that in an auction it's my
first auction most to get it for ninety
eight thousand and the end we're hoping
to get 165 refinance for one six five
fantastic hopefully we'll leave no money
in yeah fantastic and how much will that
bring your passive income to thing cuz
at the moment you're on about two
thousand right it won't be a massive
cash flow but it is no money down
there's no money down deal so yeah we'll
have a house sure so you might make what
to three hundred pound a month yeah I
reckon about three yeah three four
hundred pounds a month okay so push you
up it's all around about two for a month
but we've done that with her no as I no
money down which is pretty pretty
impressive it's your your training yeah
and things I mean that's pretty
impressive it's cool yeah so so tell me
how that structure down so it's a no
money down deal um you've bought it for
98 yep 98 thousand that's Nottingham
right yep which we think is going to be
good for capital appreciation as well
yeah ninety-eight thousand how he
financing the deal a JV partner is put
in a certain amount and the rest of its
through investors that we have met and
worked with getting a message for it we
will do when we refinance so you're what
you're you're borrowing the whole 98
thousand from it from investors yeah we
might end up doing bridging yeah if
another deal comes up so you already
completed yesterday yeah we've already
bought it using their my investors money
yeah but if I need to refinance it with
bridging I've spoken with Kevin right
got you and then we can do bridging on
that property if you need to pay the
investors back know if we if I want to
buy another property in the time before
I refinance
okay so just talking about this property
alone I know you're on the you've got a
lot going through at the moment yeah a
lot in the pipeline
you're also doing rent to essays yeah
buying HMOs although just of current but
just love this deal understand yeah so
so you bought it for ninety eight
thousand you bought all the money
investors how many investors put the
money in about for about four investors
so they gave about twenty five thousand
approximately each yeah and how much
return are you giving them what's the
what's the scheme were you gonna give
them a percentage of the profit of the
deal like we're doing on a return basis
and it's between five and eight percent
say yeah per you and how long have you
borrowed it for different people have
got different shorts the schemes so
depending it very much depends on what
the investor wants to get out of it yeah
um so some guys came to us said I have
my money for six months
yeah fixed so we know when we're going
to have to pay them back yeah I said
we're not overly sure or they're having
a baby or something else so they weren't
sure how long they wouldn't need the
short it's just six months what's the
longest Oh on some we've got a three now
give us three months three months notice
before all I need the money
yeah okay I want to so what happens if
in six months everyone says I want more
money back now please
in six months son we we will have
refinanced you know if you refinance
that you might still keep their money
just because yeah and probably two other
projects and then the plan is to keep
them up to date very much with the how
the projects going so if we share our
success any ideas that they'll want to
reinvest with us any because they'll see
how successful you are yeah okay that
makes sense so you bought it for 98 yeah
what how much money you have to spend
doing a twenty thousand and where's that
money going to come from again investors
right okay so you've actually Thoreau
says yeah so slightly more than 125 each
okay it's about thirty each so you're
gonna spend about twenty thousand doing
it up yeah so ninety-eight you've bought
it for you spent 20 grand doing it up so
you've now spent about 118 what will the
donut value be about 165 165 yeah how
have you managed to only spend 20 grand
on it but have an uplift of 85,000
pounds would be an uplift of yeah would
be a lot left of about 40,000 it's um no
because if you're buying it for 90 okay
all right so you've got an uplift of 85
because you said no so 65 yeah yeah 65
you've only spent 20 yeah so how have
you managed why is it not worth 120 we
bought it
at auction yeah I mean we worked out the
price so we knew we're buying for the
correct price yeah it had sold
previously and one of the conditions was
they had dumped cause put in the time of
course was put in at the expense of
about 8,000 pounds and then the seller
pulled out and the seller was going to
be paying 113 and then it's it's a game
isn't it to make it look like it's for
the first thing is you found a very
motivated seller yeah and you bought
from auction yeah that's the first thing
yeah tell me about buying from auction
is it scary buying from option it's my
first auction no I bid on the first lot
which I didn't get and I was semi
relieved
yeah I'm because you need to work out
exactly what figures you can be paying
so when you bought this house for 90 AK
did you know that what was the max you'd
go to was the max 98 no the max was 100
a hundred yeah and you got it for a
little bit less yeah so what how did
that feel like just walk me through what
happened in the auction I didn't go in
and talk quite late so I think the
gravel was about to go down yeah popped
up so you waited till it was getting a
bit dry yeah so got it was about 93 at
that stage and then when I'm popped up
it when went through about four or five
thousand really quickly yeah but then
the other guy must have had his limit
and didn't go any further
yeah so the guy the auctioneer just said
going going gone brilliant and how did
you feel that nervous because even
though the thing is I wouldn't recommend
people may be watching this video you
you're on the academy right yeah so
you've got a lot of support yep a lot of
help you I remember you were showing me
the day I was young too one also you
have got some experience in property now
yeah you're already financially free
yeah you've got how many properties for
properties for properties all probably
so you've got a little portfolio going
on
yep but borrowing 120,000 pounds cash
off private investors buying from an
auction these are all things that can go
wrong
yeah it doesn't a case of just buying an
a nice up and running single that house
or even hide you know this is a little
bit different right yeah but where
there's bigger risk there's usually big
reward because there needs more skill
yeah so so you've got the property from
auction you've bought it below market
value
yep the others that are done up in the
street nice presumably they're selling
for around about 160 165 yep and that's
how you know what the N value is going
to be yeah exactly so once you refinance
in six months you're then gonna maybe
pay the investors off maybe not yeah but
then you've got a property no money down
yep which you can then rent out seeing
all that yep single look and you can
make a nice little bit of profit prom
yep so what's gonna be your strategy now
moving forward then strategy moving
forward rent or LSA just to get cash
flow yeah so I've got my money yeah
because at the moment a lot of people
that I meet are almost a bit stuck at
financial freedom okay yep so it's like
I'm financially free but I've spent all
my money and what's next yeah it's which
is kind of way you got to a little bit
yeah I I was stuck yeah I probably was
stuck yeah and I know I knew I needed to
surround myself with people yeah
involved in property because making two
grand or not me yeah that might be near
enough the average salary yep might be
enough developers quit work its passive
income yeah but if you just lived off
the income one it would be pretty boring
yeah you know I'm financially free I
have a job I'm now just going to twiddle
my thumb's although people think that
would be amazing
yeah I don't know about you but I would
find that pretty boring to do nothing
I'd find it well I did had a good time
you had a baby so we're off to history
for two months and I was lovely yeah but
yeah I knew was in the Rings I wasn't
ever going to just sit home yes it homes
also your wife's working she is working
what a good salary and she's working for
yeah for the Air Force for the Air Force
yeah and ultimately I know she loves
what she does doesn't she yeah but
ultimately it would be nice for her to
be able to have the opportunity to be
able to either be financially free as
well and quit work or stay at work to
have the choice right yeah I thought I
mean she's been in there for 20 years
now so I think it'd be nice for her to
be able to leave yeah yeah so what made
you join the Academy then because if you
were if you were basically already
financially free because I know what we
did a bit of work together and I saw
still property and we did a little bit
before
all you even join the Academy yep you
became financially free and then join
the Academy which is the opposite way
around to most people most people join
the Academy and then become financially
free so you did it a little bit
backwards what we what why did you join
the Academy even after achieving
financial freedom through through my
help I think education is really really
important yeah I hadn't really done that
much before yeah and then to surround
myself really with like-minded people
yeah and then to take me to the next
level so I'd like to do developments
yeah I'd like to go to commercial to
residential yeah and it's only by
networking and talking and making make
friends with sure like-minded people
that do that so yeah yeah okay cool so
so what you've been the biggest lessons
then so far I only been on the Academy a
month but biggest lessons probably been
putting a story out there yeah I'm so
letting people know what you do yeah
putting over in a really concrete way
yeah I'm so people are happy and
confident confident in what you can
achieve for them yeah and yeah look into
all the different strategies but also
have your clear focus and I think you
have a really cool analogy if you're
going for an apple so the apples at the
end of the room keep going towards it
but enjoy the whole journey yeah nothing
less yeah sounds like something I might
say you you said something along those
lines
yeah I think if you try and chase two
rabbits you're getting on yeah but yeah
yeah okay so what does your wife think
of the whole thing then the whole
property think yeah Laura's really into
it yeah she got into put the about a
team did really well on a couple of
flips
yeah but then Air Force took over so she
made some chunks of money she made some
chunks of money and then relationships
and whatever else took her and work took
her off yeah the Air Force yeah um so
she went totally cold on it yeah and
then no she's quite came to get back
involved and what's it like living who's
ready live down in Bristol in Bristol
what's it like investing in Nottingham
and even further north and Derby when
you live far away is that manageable it
is manageable yeah
I flew up to Sunderland on Monday float
flew from Bristol Airport it's only an
hour on the bow oh you actually yeah
that's pretty cool it's cool yeah okay
there we go did you go on a plane or a
helicopter
I flew flew by plane I don't know of you
because you're a dark horse okay yeah
yeah I got a flight up there ain't got a
hard car it's brilliant actually
it's um that'll be Laura's mum for
breakfast then went property hunting
then met up with Laura sister for like
coffee in the afternoon and then met a
couple when saw a few more properties
back up with a good HMO agent and this
was Sunderland that's in Sundin yeah
yeah then drove down here and then been
on of course the last two days brilliant
sounds awesome so what why did you how
do you choose an area so you're doing
Nottingham dog which is quite close to
each other yeah now you're going to
Sunderland what Weiss and I've had white
wine Nottingham how each I'm Derby and
Nottingham a really good for a capital
appreciation and the figures come work
so I said the capital appreciation and
nearness to us back in Bristol which
probably motivate or motivated me to go
towards those areas
yeah but up in the Northeast you've got
some really good deals yeah the house
price is fantastic so I've just put an
offering for under 50 grand for a
property Wow I won't be able to get a
mortgage on for a limited company I know
you won't know if it's below 50 no but
I'll be able to is it just literally
opposite the hospital right there so
I'll be able to turn it into a mostly
Wow less than 50 grand will select so
that's why on investment yeah yeah
definitely again though it's I'm finding
it below market value isn't it yes
that's the secret
yeah what is the secret then or at least
one of the secrets one of the techniques
strategies due to being able to knock so
much money off the asking price put
yourself out there yeah I think you're
um deal finding extravaganza and never
use your own money again courses really
they open your eyes as to what is
possible and then I think the more you
put yourself out there the more that
ends up coming your way yeah so on your
on your course we sent letters to PLO
potential palos people in negative
equity yeah we did that didn't come off
but I did get a phone call from a guy
who's got a portfolio six which is an
agent in the past to him so that met up
with him Oh which is a potential deal
yeah
later on because he he didn't really
know about tax and capital gains and
yeah things
so is it educating those hold people and
then yeah right move it's really cool no
more the different websites to look at
yeah come free for rent rent yeah I
guess sending the letters as well you
say oh he didn't work but then actually
it ended up spiraling into something
else that did work yeah and that's often
the way isn't it you go and book a
viewing and it was like I spoke to des
on it on another interview yeah and he
said the books are viewing he went all
the way to Middlesboro from I think
London or somewhere and long long drive
the property was no good anyway oh
that's terrible
you know you must have something else
and then ended up following something
else on the day it was really good yeah
same with you sending letters and I
think taking action is about
implementing they're full of things you
mentioned my the training that you've
done with myself we make you do it we're
there in there yeah so it's not like you
know here's what you do go home and have
fun it's like here's what you do now
let's do it yeah and you've got no
choice but to implement and if you
implement that with the right knowledge
you've got no choice but you're going to
succeed which is what you're doing talk
to me about these joint venture partners
and so all raising finance partners
should we say how did you identify them
and how did you get them to agree to
give you 120 grand I mean that's pretty
a pretty big achievement
yeah there were people that I myself and
Dave worked with for their work
colleagues yeah so how did it come about
just by telling them yeah and what we're
doing and then asking the question do
you know anybody who might want to
invest in this project
okay so rather the same would you like
to you say don't you know anyone that
might like so yeah unless it's a softer
way it plants a seed and then what did
they say oh I love to think about it
yeah and then the following day they
come back and say oh do you want to go
for a coffee brilliant you said and you
know then it's like okay excellent yeah
and then when the cash hits your back
then yeah and it's win-win I mean
they're they're probably really happy
because they're getting 5% 10% rather
than getting half of a cent yeah it's
great for you because you've got the
knowledge to be able to make it infinity
return on investment of effectively yeah
so and was it did before people are they
all work colleagues then yeah they were
yeah and are they all kind of in on it
together
no they were all individual yeah nice
that's pretty impressive let me get in
for people to give you 30,000 pounds
approximately yeah you must have a skill
looking able to raise finance what is it
that what why do you think you were able
to be so successful an era because
there's a lot of people that would love
to be able to have that skill do you
think it's because of your track record
with property your trustworthiness do
you think it's what you said happens to
be who you know what is it that may
imagine your success in that I think
it's your trustworthiness I think yeah
so bings
yourself yeah whoever you meet and in
whatever circumstance and then probably
building the track record I wouldn't
have any problem lending you money
because I think that you can just the
way that you are I know you a little bit
and you always do what you say you're
gonna do you have it you seem
trustworthy you know that's really
important isn't it I think just to be
honest and to be yourself that's more my
viewpoint yeah
put your cards on the table yeah anyone
would be interested in this and just ask
yeah yeah put the message out there yeah
yeah just excellent view so what would
be so far from what you've done you're
financially free so from your success
might in your in your eyes it might be
little they say to me like it's not that
big a deal but to some people it's mega
yeah a fact that you now no longer have
to ever work again if you don't want
you've got an income coming in that's
mega what would you say will be the best
piece of advice that you've you've
learned throughout being a property
investor today up to date so far don't
ever take shortcuts probably or yeah
give me an example either when you're
doing a refurb yeah I'll just come back
and bite you on the bottom yeah or when
you try and search tenants because when
you've got an empty room it's very
tempting just to prevent the first
person in there yeah it comes along and
if that person's not right that'll cause
you're absolutely
brilliant advice I love that yeah so
what would you say to someone that was
thinking about booking onto the crash
course I never been to the crash course
yeah I think it's one of the most yeah
life-changing things you could probably
do yeah I think it's amazing
it's totally eye-opening yeah and it's
entertaining but entertaining and
life-changing all in one go so you'll
have an amazing weekend and it will
change your life thank you so much for
coming on the show and thank you for
your friendship yeah thank you so much
for watching the video that is the
reason why I'm doing this your success
is my oxygen every single week we've got
people becoming financially free if
you'd like to see more success units you
can do that right here but what I'd
really suggest is why don't you come and
join us at the property investors crash
course comment on my guest completely
free and I'll personally be there for
two days to help you get started you can
see what happens right here what you'll
notice is all of these stories they all
start at the crash course so come along
my guests can't wait to see you there
peace out